Vanity Fair headlines sums it up report
Ron DeSantis will formally announce his
2024 bid with Elon Musk because
apparently David Duke wasn't available
Duke who's a guy who has not been
politically relevant in like 30 years
David Duke he's the symbol of racism and
DeSantis he's a racist he's a Neo-Nazi
he's uh this is good news for DeSantis
to be called all of these things if you
are not called to these things by the
Democrats you are not making any
meaningful attack on what they hold to
be sacred on all of the crazy live
policies if they're not calling you a
racist if they're not calling you a
phobe if they're not calling you a bigot
then you just don't matter to them and
so this is good great news for Ron
DeSantis great news for Elon Elon Musk
the most prominent African-American in
the entire world they they have the
audacity to compare Elon Musk with David
Duke